yeah jackson koar another great
opportunity for him to face a team in a
beautiful daylight today great day
outside for the fastball he's going to
have to locate better tag france five
game hitting streak seven for his last
17. well in a singleness last two times
up
might drop in
the glove of dozier
ty digging for second he's in there good
hustle the three note of mitch couple of
men aboard one out
just underway in kansas city four pitch
walk loads them up for jk he hadn't
thrown a strike since he threw a strike
to france center fielder jared kelnick
held a goal for one last night but
walked a couple of times but a couple of
nights ago jared with two home runs
two two pitch with the bases loaded one
out
boy he got into that didn't he
that is off the base of the fence
two runs have scored
and they will hold hannigar at third
jarrett kelnick delivering big time here
in the first inning the mariners have a
two-nothing lead
job well done picks up a couple of rbis
he's got 37 on the season his 10th
double well he gets a fastball 97 miles
an hour it's down in the zone he just
drops the barrel on it
it's out to right center in a hurry exit
below of 108 to hits in the middle of
the fence
for logan gilbert
a nice start his last timeout this will
be his 22nd start on the year 5-5 record
of 497 era and in 101 and a third he has
115 strikeouts over just 22 walks on the
year so a nice job commanding the strike
zone 2-2 to perez
strike three call that was a beauty
absolute beauty one two three in the
first logan gilbert and mariners leaders
a little more leads off he's getting the
start at third base
payoff pitch
outside base runner there we go crawford
worked a deep count to open up the ball
game and then fly it out to the left
slice the other way base hit
manny will put up the stop sign hold
dylan at third then attend he gets it
back in quickly
good work here in the second inning
runners at the corners one out so two
aboard for time france
up the middle base hit
three-nothing mariners as moore walks
home
jp to second if your thought process is
to stay in the middle of the field you
have the ability to find the barrel
which he certainly does he can handle
pitches off the plate away so his
coverage is there bennett tindy hitting
at 280.
chase
cal throw to
france whoa a little high made it more
of an adventure than we anticipated
back-to-back strikeouts the pitch
slider swaying enemies for strike three
gilbert striking out modesty that's
going to retire the side three
strikeouts for logan gilbert already
he's retiring the first six batteries in
a row to start off his ball game this
afternoon we go to the top of the third
mariners three
jared kelneck leading things off in the
top of the third three nothing mariners
it hits this well center field giving
chase taylor out of rome bye-bye
home run jared keldich
three
make that four nothing mariners the
young man has driven in three runs today
a double and a homer one out of run in
and it brings up jake bowers.com
here's a drive deep to right and that
one's leaving the yard
home run jake bowers the mariner lead
goes to five nothing
jake bowers breaking an 0 for 16.
good for him it's fourth homer of the
season
splash that baby
460 feet that's a b low of 112 and this
is just center cut fastball right in the
middle of the plate and he hits every
bit of it make delivery super mow in the
swing by bowers yeah good release hips
open
there you go
killing more kansas city relies more on
their speed
and this one hard out towards the gap
demo
out of the gate hard he'll hold with the
single
bottom third of the order taylor dozier
rivero for the royals here in the third
taylor hits it hard he had a good night
last night and that's the royals first
base runner after logan gilbert set down
the first six
man's been really good it hasn't walked
anybody
and there's another strike out of sport
kilnik having an outstanding two at bats
two are in double and a solo home run
turns on this that'll be extra basis
over three
go for three
let's see if he does he will hold it
right there lead off double
man good stuff
fast runner he's its second 3-2 pitch
compliment aboard here
this will be trouble wind and sun
and taylor's on it
both runners will try to tag and fraley
is going to be out
forget about the runner at third he'd go
to second
he thought about third you can see by
the way he turned but man just give him
another outfield assist was that a
little deep move right there yeah looked
like he he you know he heard benny at
the last minute runner at third and the
banner will be dylan moore
and a base hit that'll pick up another
run
six nothing mariners really good day for
dylan moore
gets himself into a hitter's count and
takes care of this cutter a little cut
fastball in the middle of the plate
through the left side of the infield
three and two
oh jp sparkling play got him
one two three in the fifth nine
consecutive batters retired by logan
gilbert and another brilliant play by
j.p crawford yeah brilliant play is
correct that is barreled up by taylor
taylor also runs well jp
the diving backhanded play gets to his
feet quickly we know about the strong
throwing arm
then ty france helps him out on the
other end
terrific play
one thing we know about jp man there is
no quitting
all the tools a good major league player
needs
see carlos santana can catch up to this
one
he
will
[Music]
wow put that on his highlight reel that
was not easy
but it sacrificed the body and the
body's not feeling all that good this
time of year and shed
is over 12 in the series
one and one that count on with merefield
up the right field line
fair
so that's the royals first hit
since the third inning and wit's on with
a two out double nicky has popped out
twice once to third once to short
nice
base hit left field and the royals will
get their first run
and nikki lopez extends
his on-base streak to 28.
isabel pinch hit last night walked
started friday's game went one for four
off his fist popped up low look out holy
moly
he's fired up too
oh man
that is something look at the reacts
mitch hannah to lead off the top of the
ninth inning
[ __ ] gives it a pretty good ride left
field going back benintendi
can't get it it's gone
7-1 mariners home run mitch haniger is
34th rbi number 84.
that is a big blast well done
able to stay on a breaking ball that
time
exit v low of 100 390 feet here's the
breaking ball stays on it a state
mentioned his 34th home run that ties
him with kyle seeger for the team lead a
lot of power in that swing johann
ramirez for the final three outs average
fastball 96 miles an hour and a slider
ty francis there ramirez is there and
that's the ball game mariners win it by
the count of 7-1 to win this series
you